okay so dr oz a promoter of various
quack cures homeopathy raspberry ketones
green coffee bean extract
uh faith healing
um
okay
energy
healing and all these different things
he is running for senate as a republican
in pennsylvania there's an opponent of
his who's a great choice john fetterman
we've talked about that we've talked
about his platform and his campaign a
little bit
um
he is getting dr oz is getting the
hero's welcome on fox news probably not
coming as a surprise to most of you but
softball interview after softball
interview over the last 24 hours on a
whole bunch of different shows let's
start with uh dr oz's
interview with sean hannity last night i
could tell you in a minute what my
political philosophy is but rather than
me tell you mine what is yours right
well i'll tell you one thing for sure
any government that's large enough to
give you everything is powerful enough
to take it all away so i don't want that
that is that is a hell of a republican
talking but he knows the talking points
he has them prepared and this is the
right audience for them that's for sure
liberty and freedom and that to me means
limited government we can do it better
than folks very far away from us who
don't know our local problems the more
we can be local the more we can trust
the people in our communities the better
off we are it's funny because you know a
lot of the quack cures that he has
promoted on his show his small
government perspective would be maybe
that stuff shouldn't even be regulated i
don't like you know maybe it should just
be well if dr oz promoted this that's
the same as fda approval i'm not saying
he said that but this thinking of as
little government as possible pushes you
in that direction let's continue i
believe in energy independence that's a
big deal here in pennsylvania but we
don't as a nation want to be begging
other countries like we're starting to
do to change what they're doing with
energy because you know we're in hawk i
believe in capitalism that which means
lower taxes and regulations so people
can really compete and i respect the
constitution a brilliantly written
document that i think should be honored
on the bench and sometimes isn't we have
free market solutions that guys he has
this type i mean
this is actually it's a minute and he
hits like every republican talking point
here in healthcare i'll tell you this is
my specialty area and i spent my life
studying this we can protect against
pre-existing conditions and use free
market solutions to healthcare that
makes it affordable accessible for
everybody can you imagine he spent his
life studying healthcare
and he has promoted green coffee bean
extract raspberry ketones and all that
other stuff
it's crazy but he knows the talking
points he has been well trained um in
this next clip on fox and friends he
warns against mixing politics and
medicine can you imagine
when you mix politics and medicine you
get politics right what we witnessed not
just with uh hydroxychloroquine but
many other solutions that have been
offered subsequently is that there's a
single perspective that's allowed to get
vaccinated listen i think one of the
greatest accomplishments of america is
that we gave the world the mrna vaccines
through president trump's operational
warp speed i'm so happy that we were
able to do that and i got vaccinated and
i believe in vaccines i don't believe in
mandates
okay
it's so funny when he says you know the
hydroxychloroquine became politicized
dude
you were on tv promoting it
absent actual medical evidence that it
did anything for covet and subsequently
its authorization for emergency use was
revoked by the fda
it's you know he he has the republican
talking points down
he also has republican projection down
perfectly um here's another one where he
uh he's getting into we got to stop
canceling and and i mean he
you got to hand it to him he came in
prepared with all of the bullet points
that republicans are currently using i'm
going to serve america in his time of
need the best of my ability we need
better solutions they're out there
we ought to stop shaming and silencing
and bullying and canceling people with
ideas that are different than ours
especially when they're good ideas right
i know that play out plenty in covid and
i gotta say in medicine when you cannot
see say what you see people die
so we ought to be able to do at least
that i'm going to start i mean it's just
it's it's all backwards but this is
exact this is why his candidacy has the
potential to work
absent any actual policy
just stating these vague principles that
are abandoned when they don't coincide
with your beliefs we should be allowed
to say things when there's an idea about
medicine well you talked about
hydroxychloroquine and it was debunked
well but they shouldn't have canceled
you can't cancel can't but but it was a
bad idea it it it did not work
um here he is explaining why he's
running here's my pledge
my promise to everybody i want to be
your public servant yeah and every
choice i make will be serving the
citizens of pennsylvania and the united
states and none of them will serve the
special interests in washington many of
whom i've been to war with for most of
my career let's reinvigorate america i
think he means at war with being being
to war with them it actually means
something different but i think he means
he's been against them and let's see
that divine spark in each other because
it's there
dear god
um it's weird he even mispronounces
pennsylvania as pennsylvania
like trump does like every aspect of
this is very very trumpy here's a clip
that's kind of messed up the video is
weird
but you can hear him say a little bit
about immigration like we actually this
is the only thing i've heard him say
that approximates policy
immigration is a big problem for a
couple reasons for one we're subsidizing
cartels by the way he's running in
pennsylvania speaking of immigration
you're involved in human trafficking i
mentioned you're bringing opiates across
the border but lots of other issues as
well i think president trump was right
people should wait on mexican side of
the border if they're coming across
illegally let's deal with all the issues
there and not put law enforcement in an
impossible predicament where they're
forced now that people are in this
country to chase them down when we know
they're not coming yeah you know and of
course what's being ignored when we
don't even have to it's it's disgusting
me uh what's being ignored is they they
also apply that to people seeking asylum
they say well they should seek asylum in
mexico at an office like well a lot of
times people seeking asylum are in dire
and dangerous situations so that's why
they're coming over and at the border
saying i am seeking asylum it's a
complicated issue i'm not pretending
it's not
but dr oz presenting us the same
simplistic analysis that uh donald trump
presented so welcomed with open arms by
right-wing media we've got to be very
careful this guy has a real shot not
only at winning but it being the seat
that decides whether democrats or
republicans control the senate starting
in january of 2023. we'll have more of
this on our instagram find us on
instagram at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video